la electro negatividad es probablemente
el concepto más importante que hay que
entender en química inorgánica y vamos a
utilizar la definición de linus pauling
que se encuentra en su libro the nation
of the chemical band que en español
sería algo como la naturaleza del enlace
químico así que linus pauling nos dice
que la electro negatividad se refiere a
la capacidad de un átomo en una molécula
para atraer electrones a sí mismo ok así
que si nos fijamos en alguna molécula
que nos fijamos en alguna molécula y
comparamos dos átomos de esa molécula
así que vamos a comparar el carbono y el
oxígeno en términos de su electro
negatividad para poder hacer eso
necesitamos fijarnos aquí a la derecha
en nuestra tabla periódica orgánica que
nos muestra los elementos más usados en
química orgánica y en azul nos da la
escala de pollin para la electro
negatividad así que linus pauling de
hecho calculó la electrónica los valores
de electro negatividad para los
elementos y los puso en
esta tabla muy bien entonces eso ahora
nos permite comparar distintos elementos
en términos de sus electro negatividades
así que por ejemplo si estamos pensando
en el carbono que éste tiene vamos a
marcarlo el carbono tiene una electro
negatividad de 2.5 entonces tenemos 2.5
para el carbono ok y si nos vamos a
comparar con el oxígeno el oxígeno tiene
una electro negatividad de 3.5 muy bien
así que el oxígeno es mucho más electro
negativo que el carbono verdad entonces
es la definición nos dice que si el
oxígeno es más electrón negativo el
oxígeno tendrá una mayor capacidad para
atraer electrones verdad que lo que
puede hacer el carbono
así que si pensamos que
si pensamos en los electrones que se
encuentran digamos en este enlace
covalente ok que se encuentra entre el
carbono y el oxígeno y que están digamos
compartidos en realidad no están
compartidos de forma digamos que no es
igual la forma en la que están
compartidos verdad porque el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo verdad el
oxígeno va a jalar esos electrones ok
que se encuentran en rojo mucho más
cerca hacia el mismo verdad y como los
electrones tienen una carga negativa el
oxígeno va a obtener un digamos una
pequeña carga negativa mayor verdad así
que eso es eso es lo que va a provocar
que tengamos una lo que llamamos una
carga parcial negativa ok y que
denotamos con una letra griega delta
verdad minúscula y le ponemos el -
justamente para denotar que es negativa
así que el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y está jalando esos electrones
que están en rojo mucho más cerca del
mismo verdad y otra forma de mostrar él
de esos electrones en rojo es con una
flechita chistosa que se pone algo así
muy bien
esa es la flecha digamos que representa
que los electrones tienen una
preferencia a moverse hacia el oxígeno
verdad así que la flecha apunta la
dirección en el movimiento el perdón
apunta en la dirección del movimiento de
los electrones que tenemos en el enlace
rojo muy bien así que el carbono por su
parte está perdiendo algunos de esos
electrones en rojo verdad así que el
carbono está perdiendo un poco de esa
densidad de electrones el carbono está
perdiendo un poco de carga negativa así
que el carbono tendrá que suele ser
neutral por cierto pero como está
perdiendo digamos un poco de densidad de
electrones entonces también está
perdiendo carga negativa verdad así que
el carbono terminará siendo parcialmente
positivo y que como denotamos para el
oxígeno lo denotamos con una letra
griega delta con un signo más verdad así
que el carbono es parcialmente positivo
y el oxígeno es parcialmente
y este ejemplo no representa una
situación polarizada verdad tenemos una
carga negativa digamos de un lado
mientras que por el otro lado hay una
carga parcialmente positiva verdad así
que decimos que en realidad este es un
enlace covalente pero es un enlace
covalente polarizado debido a las
diferencias en la electro negatividad
entre los dos átomos muy bien luego
veremos esto con un poquito más de
detalle vamos a ver algunos ejemplos
aquí vamos a mostrar la diferencia en la
electro negatividad entre dos átomos muy
bien así que por ejemplo no sé si
pensamos en una molécula que tiene dos
carbonos digamos que tenemos una
molécula que tiene dos carbonos unidos
de esta forma a través de un enlace
covalente que de una vez valdría la pena
ponerlo en rojo que es digamos el enlace
que vamos a considerar vamos a pensar
qué pasa con los electrones que están en
rojo de este enlace así que para este
ejemplo cada carbono tiene el mismo
valor de electro negatividad verdad cada
uno tiene un valor d
2.5 como ya vimos aquí está 2.5 y 2.5
así que el carbono los 2 carbonos tienen
el mismo valor de electrón negatividad y
la diferencia entre estos valores nos da
una la diferencia nos da 0 verdad es un
valor cero lo cual significa que los
electrones en rojo no se van a mover
hacia ninguna dirección
digamos preferencia al verdad
digamos no van a elegir mejor un carbono
y por cierto aquí me faltó un enlace no
van a elegir una dirección hacia no van
a elegir perdón una dirección
preferencial hacia alguno de los dos
carbonos simplemente tratarán de estar
en medio y van a tratar d
de estar compartidos entre estos dos
átomos de carbono así que este es un
enlace covalente y no hay una situación
polarizada
no hay una situación polarizada creada
porque no hay una diferencia en la
electro negatividad así que llamamos a
este que es un enlace covalente
covalente no polar no polar porque
justamente no tenemos una preferencia de
estos electrones a irse en alguna
dirección vamos a hacer algún otro
ejemplo vamos ahora a comparar el
carbono con el hidrógeno muy bien vamos
a comparar el carbono
con el hidrógeno
ahí tenemos nuestra molécula que tiene
un enlace entre carbono y un hidrógeno
ahí tenemos esa molécula y vamos a
remarcar por supuesto el enlace entre
estos dos átomos muy bien y ahora
queremos saber qué es lo que ocurre con
esos electrones que están entre el
carbono y el hidrógeno y hemos visto que
el carbono tiene una electro negatividad
de 2.5 ahora bien si nos fijamos en
nuestra tabla periódica orgánica podemos
ver que la electro negatividad del
hidrógeno es de 2.12 punto 1 así que eso
nos da una diferencia de 0.4 muy bien
así que la diferencia en la electro
negatividad entre estos dos átomos es
realmente pequeño verdad así que muchos
libros de texto podrían considerar que
este enlace entre el carbono y el
hidrógeno sigue siendo un enlace
covalente no polar muy bien eso es según
algunos libros de texto vamos
y algún otro ejemplo que vamos a ver el
ejemplo que teníamos antes el del
carbono con el oxígeno muy bien vamos a
poner nuestro enlace del carbono con el
oxígeno en alguna molécula ok y vamos a
ver qué ocurre con este enlace o estos
electrones que se encuentran en este
enlace entonces y si nos recordamos el
valor del electrón negatividad para el
carbono es nuevamente de 2.5 mientras
que del oxígeno como habíamos visto era
de 3.5 verdad
3.5 y eso nos da una diferencia de 1 en
la diferencia es 1 y esa diferencia es
suficiente para poder considerar que
tenemos un enlace covalente polar muy
bien así que este es un enlace covalente
polar entre el carbono y el oxígeno
de hecho deberíamos escribirlo este es
un enlace covalente polar
un enlace covalente polar así que cuando
pensamos en los electrones que tenemos
en rojo estos electrones van a ser
digamos atraídos más cerca hacia el
oxígeno dándole una carga parcialmente
negativa al oxígeno y por otro lado va a
darle una carga parcialmente positiva al
carbono verdad y como eso es debido a la
densidad de electrones está densidad de
electrones se está moviendo digamos se
está alejando del carbono y el carbono
por eso es que tiene una carga
parcialmente positiva y aquí podemos ver
la diferencia de la electro negatividad
verdad esta diferencia de hecho es 1 y
por eso es que va a ser considerado como
un enlace polar covalente ok ahora si te
das cuenta en el ejemplo anterior
teníamos una diferencia de 0.4 y ese es
considerado un enlace covalente no polar
así que en medio entre estos dos valores
entre 0.4 y
debe haber como el límite debe estar la
diferencia entre los enlaces no polares
los enlaces covalentes no polares y los
enlaces covalentes polares y muchos
libros de texto te dirían te dirán que
aproximadamente entre estos dos tipos de
comportamiento verdad aproximadamente
digamos el valor que los que los divide
es aproximadamente de 0.5 ok entonces si
la diferencia en la electro negatividad
es mayor o igual que 0.5 puede
simplemente considerar que es un enlace
esencialmente covalente polar verdad si
la diferencia del electrón negatividad
es menor que 0.5 entonces lo vamos a
considerar como un enlace covalente no
polar ahora debería remarcar aquí que
estamos usando la escala de pollin para
la electro negatividad y en realidad hay
distintas escalas para la electro
negatividad así que estos números
digamos no son no son no son absolutos
no son únicos hay muchas otras
diferencias relativas pero en realidad
lo que estamos considerando aquí es
diferencia relativa en la electro
negatividad y eso es en lo que más nos
vamos a estar centrando vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo ahora vamos a comparar el
oxígeno con el hidrógeno muy bien
entonces vamos a pensar en una molécula
nuevamente que tenga el oxígeno aquí
verdad y que esté unido con un hidrógeno
muy bien así que vamos a pensar qué pasa
con estos electrones que tenemos en el
enlace muy bien así que ya hemos visto
estos valores de electro negatividad
para estos dos átomos el oxígeno tiene
un valor de 3.5 verdad mientras que el
hidrógeno tiene un valor de 2.1 así que
esa es la diferencia del electrón
negatividad sería de 1.4 es de 1.4 así
que este es un enlace covalente polar
por lo que dijimos anteriormente y como
el oxígeno es más electro negativo que
el hidrógeno verdad entonces los
electrones en rojo van a moverse más
cerca del oxígeno dándonos una carga
parcialmente negativa
el oxígeno y una carga parcialmente
positiva para el hidrógeno muy bien así
que vamos a hacer otro ejemplo vamos a
considerar ahora el carbono con el litio
ok entonces vamos a considerar el
carbono digamos el carbono que está
unido con el litio muy bien y nuevamente
estamos interesados en ver qué pasa con
los electrones que están en este enlace
verdad entre el carbono y el litio y el
electrón negativo el valor de electrón
negatividad para el carbono es de 2.5
como ya hemos visto muy bien ahora
tendríamos que checar de nuevo en
nuestra tabla periódica y ver cuál es el
valor para el litio y podemos observar
que el valor para el litio es de 1
verdad entonces el valor de electrón
negatividad para el litio es de 1 y así
la diferencia que obtenemos es de 1.5
verdad
a diferencia de 1.5 y si a través de lo
que hemos visto anteriormente podríamos
considerar que este es un enlace
covalente polar ahora bien
en este caso el carbono es mucho más
electro negativo que el litio así que
los electrones en rojo van a moverse en
dirección del carbono del átomo de
carbono y por lo tanto el carbono va a
obtener una carga ligeramente más
negativa verdad debido a esta densidad
de electrones que va a tener así que va
a ser parcialmente negativo y el litio
va a estar perdiendo densidad de
electrones y por lo tanto será
parcialmente positivo verdad ahora aquí
estamos tratando este enlace como si
fuera un enlace covalente por lar pero
como veremos en unos minutos también
podríamos considerar esto como un enlace
iónico verdad y eso solo va a depender
en los valores de la del electrón
negatividad que estemos trabajando para
para cierto tipo de reacciones químicas
verdad así que podríamos considerar que
esto es un enlace iónico también además
en un enlace covalente polar así que
vamos a ver cómo vamos a ver otro
ejemplo de un compuesto que tengamos
certeza de que es único verdad y el
ejemplo más claro y más inmediato es el
del cloruro de sodio que entonces vamos
a empezar con el cloruro de sodio
tenemos
sodio y el cloro ok y vamos a pretender
que el enlace que hay en estos por
ahorita es un enlace covalente muy bien
digamos vamos a pensarlo solo por este
momento y vamos a vamos a pensar quizás
deberíamos poner los electrones que
tiene el cloro de esta forma muy bien
entonces sabemos que este enlace
consiste de dos electrones digamos de
esta forma vamos a hacerlo todavía un
poco más claro tenemos estos dos
electrones y vamos a fijarnos en la
diferencia del electrón negatividad
entre el sodio y el cloro muy bien así
que vamos a irnos nuevamente a nuestra
tabla periódica orgánica y vemos que la
electro negatividad del sodio es de 0.9
y del cloro es de 3 muy bien el cloro es
de 3 tenemos que el
el sodio es de 0.9 el cloro es de 3 y
por lo tanto tenemos una diferencia de
electrón y negatividad de 2.1 así que el
cloro es mucho más electro negativo que
el sodio y resulta ser que es mucho más
electro negativo que realmente no va a
necesitar ya compartir los electrones
con el sodio verdad va a robar esos
electrones y cuando digámosle dibujemos
esta molécula vamos a mostrar el cloro
vamos a mostrar el cloro de esta forma
está rodeado de sus electrones pero
además ya va a tener estos dos
electrones que estaban digamos en este
enlace mientras que el sodio se queda
simplemente sin ese electrón que tenía
originalmente verdad entonces
en este caso el cloro tiene un electrón
extra verdad lo cual nos da una carga
formal negativa de 1 y
y realmente ya no estamos con ya no
estamos hablando de cargas parciales
aquí verdad el cloro toma completamente
una carga negativa debido a este
electrón que ha robado verdad y por lo
tanto el sodio también ha perdido es el
electrón así que termina con una carga
positiva formal perdón una carga forma
positiva como de esta forma así que
sabemos aquí que este es un enlace
iónico entre estos dos iones y esto
realmente es lo que representa un enlace
iónico la diferencia en su electro
negatividad verdad y esa diferencia
debería estar digamos contenida en
digamos
si vamos a ponerlo por aquí vamos a
aquí la línea muy bien entonces esa
diferencia entre los enlaces iónicos y
los enlaces covalentes polares debe
estar entre 1.5 y 2.1 verdad y muchos
libros de texto dicen que tiene que ser
de 1.7 ok entonces si estamos más arriba
de 1.7 generalmente ya está considerado
como un enlace iónico mientras que si
estás por abajo de 1.7 estás en en el
rango del enlace covalente polar ok pero
ese no siempre tiene que ser no siempre
tiene que ser el caso verdad como vimos
en este ejemplo anterior y déjenme
quizás valdría la pena remarcarlo en
este ejemplo anterior nosotros teníamos
por ejemplo que aquí el carbono era
mucho más electro negativo que el litio
entonces tenía una carga parcial
negativa mientras que el litio tenía una
carga parcial positiva y a veces
podríamos tratar este enlace como enlace
covalente oa veces podríamos tratarlo
como este enlace de digamos que teníamos
acá abajo que es un enlace iónico o que
de hecho vamos a dibujar
el digamos el carbono y el litio si lo
estuviéramos tratando como un enlace
iónico muy bien entonces aquí tenemos
nuestro carbono tenemos nuestro carbono
con estos tres enlaces y digamos que
tiene aquí los dos electrones que ha
tomado de este enlace y dejamos el litio
simplemente aquí separado en este caso
el litio tiene una carga formal positiva
mientras que el carbono tiene una carga
formal negativa
y en este caso lo estamos tratando de
este como si fuera un enlace iónico
verdad con nuestras cargas formales
completas de digamos aquí en este
ejemplo aunque y esto es bastante útil
para algunas reacciones de la química
orgánica y lo que quiero remarcar aquí
en estas divisiones de 1.7 en realidad
no es absoluta verdad esta división no
es absoluta sino simplemente es algo
relativo y podríamos dibujar la
estructura de puntos arriba y podríamos
considerar lo correcto verdad como lo
teníamos en este ejemplo así que este es
un repaso digamos una una visión general
de lo que es la electro negatividad y a
pesar de que hemos estado trabajando con
números en este vídeo en vídeos
posteriores no nos va a interesar tanto
estos números sino simplemente vamos a
fijarnos en las diferencias relativas de
electro negatividad eso es lo que es
realmente importante para entender